luego el esperma debe pasar a través del
cuello del útero una abertura en el
útero por lo general este se mantiene
bien cerrado pero aquí el cuello uterino
está abierto durante unos días mientras
que la mujer ovula
el esperma nada a través de la mucosidad
cervical que ha adquirido una
consistencia más líquida para facilitar
el paso
una vez en el interior del cuello del
útero el esperma sigue nadando hacia el
útero Aunque millones morirán tratando
de hacerlo a través de la mucosidad
algunos espermatozoides se quedan atrás
atrapados en los pliegues del cuello del
útero pero luego pueden continuar el
viaje como un respaldo del primer grupo
en el interior del útero las
contracciones uterinas musculares ayudan
a los espermatozoides en su viaje hacia
el óvulo sin embargo las células
residentes del sistema inmunológico de
la mujer confunden el esperma con
Invasores extraños y así destruyen miles
de espermatozoides más
luego la mitad de la cabeza del
espermatozoide ingresa en la trompa de
falopio mientras que la otra mitad nada
hacia el tubo que contiene el óvulo no
fertilizado Ahora solo unos cuantos
miles quedan dentro de la trompa de
falopio minúsculo cilios empujan el
óvulo hacia el útero para continuar los
espermatozoides deben surgir contra este
movimiento para llegar al óvulo algunos
espermatozoides se quedan atrapados en
los cilios y mueren durante esta parte
del viaje químicos en el tracto
reproductivo hacen que las membranas que
cubren las cabezas de los
espermatozoides cambien como resultado
los espermatozoides se vuelven
hiperactivos y nadan más duro y más
rápido hacia su destino
por fin el espermatozoide llega al óvulo
solo unas pocas docenas de los 300
millones de espermatozoides originales
quedan
[Música]